we're here in Basel Switzerland the town
best known for its pharmaceutical giants
and its art fair but every spring for
eight days the watching jewelry industry
completely takes over
welcome to Basel
there's been a watching jewelry show in
Basel since 1917 that's a 98 years of
continuous shows in the 1970s it broke
off from a larger Industrial Exhibition
and became its own fare in the 80s they
added International exhibitors and in
2013 this new Hertzog and demure and
design building opened new halls have
over 1.5 million square feet of
exhibition space this week that will
play host to 1,500 brands from over 40
countries the booths here in hall one or
ocular for three stories they have
marble and hardwood floors and for most
of them there's espresso on demand there
will be about a hundred and fifty
thousand guests coming through the halls
before the show is over including
members of the public on Saturday and
Sunday
every year basel world has a slightly
different atmosphere this year there are
two questions on everyone's lives the
first is how the recent strength of the
swiss franc is going to affect prices
and the second is how traditional
watchmakers are going to respond to the
evolving SmartWatch market I guess we'll
have our answer soon enough
you